when you're reaching out to people like  yourself where 10 minutes of your time  could change my world how do you ask  with being respectful and not outwardly  coming out and asking by being  respectful  I think it really really comes down to  compassion communication like I really  appreciate when someone takes the extra  30 seconds of breath to be like I really  get that I'm bothering you with your  family right now but can I just take a  selfie I just even appreciate that like  it's just it's someone who's consciously  just trying to tell you I know you  probably don't even love this thing  right now I'm not sure if you do or you  don't but I want to acknowledge that I  know acknowledgment is incredibly  powerful so to answer your question I  think the positive communication of that  acknowledgment really matters to people  that are getting bombarded and gives you  a half a prayer of it Landing all of it  is based on expectation on your end